My name is Ali.
I came to Istanbul
about two years ago
with a multinational company.
I love Istanbul.
I love the city, but
I just hated traffic.
I realized that 8 out
of 10 cars in traffic
have only the driver.
And I decided to do
something about it.
One interesting thing
is I started fundraising
at the same time as well.
And one investor was
like this will never
work here because this is
not part of the culture.
And I kind of
disagreed with him,
and I took it as a challenge
to prove him wrong.
So I started
hitchhiking in the city.
And it's like in Istanbul
doing that you should be crazy
or an entrepreneur.
So I started hitchhiking.
And obviously,
hitchhiking on the street,
no one will pick you up.
But I hitchhike inside
the residential compound
where I live, where there
is gated security, which
is the main feature.
It's one of our biggest
features, which is communities.
People trust each other
inside communities.
I hitchhike and the first car--
the first time I tried it,
the first car stopped
and picked me up.
And this was the
idea behind launching
Volt around communities.
This is where it came to life.
It's not just a market place.
It's not only about drivers
offering their empty seats
to passengers going
in the same direction.
It's not only about
supply and demand.
In our case, we have
so many parts moving.
So you have drivers
driving around,
and passengers going
in the same direction.
But they need to be going in
the same direction from point A
to point B at the same time.
So that's a fourth element.
And they need to
trust each other.
So we call it a five
vector marketplace.
It's not only supply and demand.
It's not only chicken and egg.
It's supply, demand,
geolocation, time, and trust.
And that's really one of
the toughest challenges
we have to crack.
And we're still working on.
To solve one aspect
is the communities,
which we already spoke about.
We launched inside universities,
inside big companies.
We launched inside big
residential compounds.
Which solves anyway,
the geolocation.
The time, because
most people come
to this building at the same
time, leave at the same time.
And the trust, because if
I see-- even if there's
someone who works at Google
or at Procter and Gamble
that I don't know, there's
a chance the company is big.
If I see the logo of this
company on their profile,
it means that they have
an email at this company
so I can trust them.
The way we've
solved it is we made
it effortless for
the driver to use.
Before, we required planning.
So we required you to say, hey,
I'm leaving today at 8:00 PM.
But in inner city, things
have to be real time.
And that's a big
learning we've learned.
So we made it effortless for
the driver to use, in the sense
that you don't have to plan.
You just have to
fire up the apps
and just say start driving.
When you fire up the
app and start driving,
your earn Volt miles for
every kilometer you travel.
So for every kilometer,
you earn one mile.
If you get a passenger,
you earn two miles.
And then there are
other rules that can
make you accelerate your miles.
And these miles-- you can use
them for gifts or discounts
at certain outlets.
So it makes it engaging for the
driver to stay on the system
because it's effortless.
And there's gamification
with the miles.
You see levels and everything.
So the drivers
will stick around,
and are sticking around.
And at the same
time, passengers,
whenever they fire
up the app, they
see drivers moving on the map,
which gets the marketplace
to start rolling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]